[Música]
entrevista de prensa en directo américa
en france 24 ya está conmigo en el
estudio rosa pérez más de borrosa
bienvenida buena mañana de jueves vamos
a abrir esta revista de prensa con el
periódico 'el país' que en su edición
online tanto la edición españa como la
de américa con la siguiente información
bruselas prepara una ofensiva comercial
para frenar el avance de rusia es de
china y rúsia en latinoamérica un texto
que ha preparado bernardo de miguel
buenos dias de hable efectivamente y un
texto ilustrado de forma muy
significativa también con la imagen del
presidente argentino alberto fernández
junto con vladimir putin en moscú el 3
de febrero de este año recordemos esto
fue antes de la invasión rusa de ucrania
en todo caso este artículo como bien
decías hace referencia a un documento
interno de la comisión europea enviado a
los ministros de exteriores del bloque
comunitario y al que ha tenido acceso el
diario 'el país' en este documento la
comisión alerta de que europa la unión
europea está perdiendo terreno
peligrosamente en países americanos
cruciales para el suministro
internacional de materias primas y
también para mantener el orden
multipolar y que esté vacío que está
dejando europa o la unión europea más
particularmente está siendo ocupado por
los intereses económicos de china y por
los intereses políticos de rusia bien
hablando de china china ha multiplicado
por 26 su inversión en la región entre
2000 y 2020 y en muchos casos ya es el
primer socio comercial de distintos
países latinoamericanos en otros casos
es el segundo habiendo desplazado así a
eeuu oa la unión europea en estos
puestos privilegiados en términos
comerciales también indica este artículo
que 21 de los 33 países de la región ya
se han adherido a la llamada nueva ruta
de la seda de china por otro lado en
términos políticos la comisión europea
alerta de que hay una nueva tendencia
una nueva izquierda en la región no
protagonizada por gabriel boric
petro por xiomara castró y que podría
culminar incluso con lula en brasil y
son a mandatarios que la comisión ve
como menos atlantistas y más abiertos a
otro tipo de alianzas y que además no
acaban de compartir la posición que ha
adoptado bruselas o washington respecto
a la guerra en ucrania y ahora vamos a
eso porque es importante cuando hablamos
en términos de dinero nos cuenta este
artículo que la unión europea dispone de
3.400 millones de euros para cooperar
con la región latinoamericana entre el
año de aquí hasta el año 2027 y que
eventualmente podría prepararse otro
paquete de hasta 8 mil millones de euros
que se anunciaría cuando españa asuma la
presidencia de la unión europea en el
segundo semestre de 2023 una ocasión a
que también se aprovecharía para
realizar la primera cumbre entre ambas
regiones desde el 2015 no de hecho que
haya habido pues ya ocho años sin
cumbres bilaterales entre las dos
regiones muestra un poco el estado de
abandono de estas relaciones y bien
recordemos comisionado de la unión
europea para asuntos exteriores este
dinero hay que invertirlo en áreas
estratégicas y de qué hablamos pues de
que por ejemplo bolivia argentina y
chile con disponen del 60 por ciento de
las reservas mundiales de litio o de que
venezuela argentina y brasil tienen
importantes reservas de petróleo y gas
hidrocarburos que la unión europea pues
quiere teniendo en cuenta que está
perdiendo a su principal socio a rusia
cambiamos ahora rosa de información
porque los periodistas el 'new york
post' steven el vago y ven que ashley
entrevistaron al atacante salman rushdie
y destacan también elogió al ayatolás de
irán y se declaró sorprendido el
atacante de que el autor haya
sobrevivido de que no haya muerto lo
entrevisté a una cárcel exactamente fue
una entrevista de unos 15 minutos según
nos cuentan los periodistas del new york
post' ahadi matar recordemos el hombre
de 24 años como decías acusado de atacar
al escritor no al autor de los adversos
satánicos sobre el que el ayatolá
jomeiní pues realizó una petición
digamos de matarlo en
1989 bien en todo caso -ha de matar dijo
bajo recomendaciones de su abogado que
no había seguido explícitamente esta
petición eso sí aseguró que tiene una
buena imagen del ayatolá iraní y que
considera que es una buena persona pero
que por el contrario considera que rudy
no lo ve como una buena persona dice
asegura que actuó solo por otro lado
también explica a los periodistas que
sólo leyó una par de páginas de los
versos satánicos' pero que había visto
muchos vídeos de rossi en youtube por
otro lado también explica que durmió en
la institución en las afueras dice que
lo considero un lugar muy bonito en la
institución donde se nos iba a dar una
conferencia y donde fue atacado y su
madre explica que desde hacía meses
estaba recluido y aislado en el sótano
de la casa por otro lado también
que la fiscalía no ha permitido que
pueda salir en libertad bajo fianza por
temor a que se le recompense
económicamente por el acto digamos que
cometió no por otro lado también acaba
este texto recordando que en 1991 fue
asesinado el traductor japonés de este
libro y que a los pocos días fue
apuñalado el traductor italiano pero que
sí que sobrevivió y pues para terminar
como bien decías nos dice hadi matar
bueno le dice a los periodistas del new
york post que nos lo trasladan que está
sorprendido de que rise y haya
sobrevivido imagínate lo sé pues
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información de esta revista de prensa
pero bueno comentemos rápidamente 100
días se cumplen del asesinato de la
periodista de al yazira shirín agua que
así es y al yazira así como la autoridad
palestina llevan el caso a la corte
penal internacional ante el bloqueo de
la investigación en israel y también
ante la edad pues inacción de eeuu de
que lleve a cabo una investigación
independiente
que puede ser una buckler recordemos era
palestina estadounidense ahora sí rosa
la estudió muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información de
revista prensa mañana con más pasamos a
saludar a nuestra primera mitad del día